our two days of national mourning have
been declared in burkina faso after at
least 35 civilians were shot dead during
an attack and according to the
government 80 armed men have also been
killed a warning some viewers may find
the following images disturbing the
attack was launched on an army base in
our Binda and a nearby town violence has
increased in burkina faso after the
military offensive on a began an
offensive against armed groups in
november there's been no claim of
responsibility so far for this latest
attack solidarity once again we have to
think about solidarity and national
cohesion people women for the most part
we're getting water and got murdered in
cold blood by the terrorists while they
were retreating we must show compassion
with the population that is why all
flags will fly at half-mast for two days
and all Christmas celebrations are
canceled
well Burkina Faso was once a pocket of
calm in the Sahel region but security
has deteriorated over the past five
years the removal of longtime president
Blaise compari in October 2014 created a
security vacuum which has been exploited
by several armed groups as well as
homegrown fighters groups from Mali
affiliated with al-qaeda and ISIL have
crossed the border and added to the
unrest the UN says more than 700 people
have been killed since 2015 and almost
half a million have been displaced let
speak to our regional correspondent
amedy trees who's in Abuja Nigeria
following this story for his amid so one
of the deadliest assaults in booking a
fossil in the past five years what more
first are you hearing about the
circumstances of this latest attack
well basically fully what the official
sources are telling us is that the
attackers were trying to overrun a
military base and in the process they
were repelled as they were withdrawing
then they targeted civilians many of the
people who were killed many of the
civilians 35 who were killed when be
members of private citizens who have
been early on displaced by the violence
in Britain
especially moving Burkina Faso you know
I've taken shelter in that part of the
country when this attack happened some
of them went to effect water and some of
them were gathering firewood and stuff
like that for their daily lives and when
these fighters were treating according
to government sources they targeted them
killing them instantly the government is
confirming that more than 80 of these
attackers have been killed but what
probably we will see in the coming weeks
this was anticipated by many people by
the way that these periods when armies
in the region are stepping up operations
we will see more of such attacks it's
been rare for many countries in the
Exile who've been targeted by Boko Haram
or ISIL affiliated organizations to see
civilians been targeted except in the
case of Nigeria Cameroon and Chad most
of these attacks who are actually on
military bases as we've seen in recent
times but increasingly they are being
becoming targets of these attacks yeah
and it's not just book you know Faso is
it 2019 has been a deadly year for as
you say the militaries of countries in
the Sahel region we saw the attack in
Nazaire a few weeks ago why is the
security situation worsening in this
part of Africa in the Sahel despite the
presence of thousands of French and
regional troops well basically that's
what many West Africans won't understand
for example the the war on violence in
Nigeria has been there for a decade now
and Nigerians wouldn't understand how an
army that has been able to deal with
echo and deal with the civilian civil
wars in Liberia and Sierra Leone and up
to now cannot deal with this problem and
there are also people who feel that the
frenches have been there in mali burkina
faso and other parts of the cell 4500
french troops are there and yet these
attacks continue there are apart from
the french forces there are thousands of
other international forces stationed in
mali for example under melisma
to take care of these problems but
you have to appreciate the development
over the last 10 years not only in the
Sahel region but also in North Africa as
well as the Middle East a lot of arms
are coming in from these areas after the
fall of ISIL in the Middle East after
the after the fall of Gaddafi in Libya
these these health regions are vast and
they have territories that their
militaries cannot mine properly because
some areas of water spread thousands of
kilometers by the way and these armies
may not have enough resources to deal
with that so the attackers or the gunman
or fighters that are moving basically
moving in with ease to set up bases and
also launch attacks thank you for that
immediate risk in Abuja Nigeria force